you
hello everyone once again this is
extinction week now what I originally
planned I had some other subject for
this week but on unfortunate or
fortunately I guess I got sidetracked by
a discussion I had with fell by a name
of guy McPherson he's an extinction
theorist he's an environmentalist
conservationist and so we had a little
discussion there going on you can see it
over there in the my extinction page and
Facebook and yeah we we disagree
disagree quite a bit not on the fact
that the extinction of man is imminent
there we seem to agree but we agree we
disagree on the reasons we have
different proposals different theories
for why humans are going to become
extinct in my case it's a it's not a
prediction okay I want you to understand
that I'm not making a prediction when I
say humans are going to become extinct
and you're saying well that really
sounds like a prediction to me so let me
put it in the right context what I'm
proposing is a mechanism I'm proposing
an extinction Theory I can only talk
about the extinction of past animals and
so I'm offering an extinction theory in
other words how the animals in the past
disappeared then from there I'm
projecting it to the future and saying
humans are going to die in the same way
why because they have no way of eluding
the same process mechanism you know that
these animals were forced to face and
neither technology neither our
intelligence our ability to foresee
events and react
none of that hat is an antidote to
what's coming up to what the other
animals faced and all that does is show
that we
I mean if we accept that right all that
does is show that we're just another
animal in the Garden of Eden
we're not the caretakers we thought of
ourselves as the Gardeners that got
designated as us as the gardener's no
we're just another little animal there
okay and we are biological from a
biological sample we are biologically
animals that's what we are we eat we
sleep we do everything that all other
animals do and it's those biological
things that are going to cause our
extinction that's the general picture I
discussed the other day first the
discussion I had with guy McPherson on
Monday I discussed mass extinctions how
I believed they occurred and yesterday
we discussed here with my son who's on
the other side of the desk here I
discussed some other issues little bits
and pieces that we kind of need to get a
picture of what happened to the animals
in the past that may have not been clear
on Monday and those have to do with know
how the plants disappeared because what
I'm suggesting there was an economic
breakdown the ecology fell apart the
ecological pyramid overturned all you
have all these trophic levels you have
on the top usually the carnivores they
are a smaller group you have the larger
herbivores on which they depend then
usually there's a ten to one ratio in
other words the herbivores for a normal
healthy pyramid the herbivores have to
outnumber the carnivores by a 10 to 1
ratio more or less that's that's an
estimate that's been thrown out there by
geologists now in colleges biologists
and other people and then you also have
to have like a ten to one ratio between
primary production and herbivores so you
know a healthy pyramid looks more or
less like this isosceles triangle or
whatever and
and what is it it's a ten to one ratio
from the bottom up
ten to one from primary production to
the Carnot herbivores and ten to one
ratio of herbivores to carnivores what
happens when that overturns and it
becomes like this triangle that's upside
down it's standing on its point on its
peak well then we have a problem because
now you have the many chasing after the
few that's essentially my theory and
that's for mass extinctions but that we
have a more serious problem because we
can't even answer
what a background extinction is and the
main reason no no this didn't know this
term has been around on it and I want to
clarify a little bit about that term
okay that's important if you look up the
term background extinction just look it
up
you know dictionary or just google it or
whatever and what you're finding is that
there's no definition of that term and
yes you go like to the Wikipedia and
there's an article called background
extinction so when you go in there what
you really find is that people are
talking about the background extinction
right it's a mathematical issue they're
saying
yeah yeah what they're saying here is
look over the course of the history of
life on Earth well you know we had these
mass extinctions where it's very choppy
and very clearly defined in the
background you had lots of animals that
came into view and then disappeared and
so they don't coach me each one of those
and say well how did this guy die you
know how did the Dimetrodon die or how
did you know that you Daffy asaurus died
and they don't care about that they say
what was the rate what was the
extinction rate and so they they traced
and more or less made histograms you
know made a curve out of all this and
they said well you know this is the
background extinction rate
but what is a background extinction we
have no definition of this term just
just turn back for an extinction what
they do is just go directly to the rate
and so I had to define this term because
a problem came up yep you know you can
say well you know for example I define
it as the death of a single species and
you say well that's your definition bill
who cares about it but there's a reason
for it you know if you go to the
Neanderthal extinction you say well how
did the under thought die did he die you
know mass extinction
oh no he disappeared in the background
extinction so what does that mean what
was the rate
what was the going right well what was
the rock market at the time you know
we're gonna talk about percentages and
and you know this of numbers in the
background what is this nonsense about a
background extinction rate I mean you
know how did Neanderthal die did he die
all alone did he die in a mass
extinction
well obviously everybody was gonna say
he died all alone and so he died in a
background extinction he died all alone
we have a definition for a background
extinction background extinction means
the death of one species and the term
background is terrible for that but
that's the way they used it they used
that as a rate so they said the
background extinction rate that's how
the word background got put in there
okay I like the term background because
it gives this feeling like there's this
party going on and one guy Canada
you know fades away and no notice apply
in that sense if only one species dies I
was kind of like a background thing like
a side thing except when that species is
like the Neanderthals and he comes to
the floor he becomes very important or
another one very important one but
woolly mammoth you know they disappeared
in a background extinction and what
they're saying is that all these animals
you know they're uh they're there and
they slowly die in the background but
it's like we don't care about the causes
we don't care how they died they just
die it's like they disappeared and we're
not concerned about how yeah seemed
self-evident
yeah yeah it's like we don't care about
how they died we care about what the
rate of going rate is you know it's and
so they never defined the term well I
think it's because it happened so often
that it's like you don't have to it's
just natural thing so they don't
question it moist they just kind of say
okay how often do species die off on
their own correct math ones that were
interested in they okay what happened
something happened on this day yeah in
this year because we have this layer of
rock that's obviously pointing to some
major disappearance at least change
whatever the change was something had
people started dying a lot yeah yeah but
when we're talking about background this
thinkin's they uh yeah but you know what
it becomes important when people say
well how did the Nano those die or how
did the woolly mammoths die and that and
that and that's when people said well
they done in the background extinction
we say yeah yeah it died alone and you
know one other and that's another issue
that's got to be clarified because once
we bring man into the picture if it gets
very complex because people get
sidetrack and say well you know man men
killed the dodo man killed the passenger
pigeon man killed the tasmanian tiger
weak routed him out or the environment
change or we change the environment for
them or brought some kind of predator
into the region or competitor or
whatever and so they blame us we we were
blamed for all modern maybe last 10,000
years more mother of all the modern
extinctions in fact we're even blamed
for Fernando thought which died like
forty thousand years ago so since forty
thousand years ago to the present we're
responsible for all extinctions man is
the cause of all extinctions that's the
way the establishment looks at this the
paleontology establishment is in general
they say well who could have done it we
are so what happened to all those
animals that died all by themselves
before man acquired conscience oh yeah I
think they attribute any subsequent
um extinctions to us because we have
such a potent effect and we change the
landscape so much that you kind of have
to say okay we at least had our hand in
some in in in the in the extinctions of
all the ones that were while we were
alive did we but that's just the first
thing you think oh yeah right cuz he
just say okay what else could be killing
all these things maybe maybe maybe the
climate maybe it's the methane yeah but
we've with the methods we're just such a
changing force well what are the things
that we do is we change environment we
put cement where there was jungle and
and that tends to crowd out the animals
and then you get into their
density-dependent birth rates and that
kind of thing and that does help drive
them to extinction I'm not gonna say
that doesn't but see we have to
distinguish what man did in the last
maybe 2000 years you could say and what
man and what happened before then did
the woolly mammoths die in the same way
the ones in Siberia for example those
died like maybe 8,000 10,000 years ago
they're not really sure exactly when but
they got in the middle of nowhere where
there were no people essentially you
know the Siberia same with the masses
indeed I'd before that how about the
what is it the short-nosed bear you know
he he died maybe around the time of
nanda though maybe thirty thousand years
ago how about the woolly rhino he was
there also in the days of NAND earth on
a diet
disappeared about thirty thousand maybe
or so years ago
there's hippo maybe he was a woolly
hippo also in Europe all these european
animals they're no longer around lions
disappeared eventually we could have
killed those yeah but I'm saying you
know you always look at you know how did
they die did we kill all these animals
and and what happened before humans
acquired conscience I mean how did those
animals die
now we can't you can't blame us worthy
it seems that the dinosaurs hopefully
you know we were not around and you know
there's the extinction and then you have
the extinction of the erectus recti the
Homo erectus Heidelberg did we kill
those as well I mean we probably never
even saw you know a human just modern
him and he probably never saw Heidelberg
you know so how did those die was it
Neanderthal who killed his parents and
so we got a problem here because you can
blame the new ones you know like the
passenger pigeon and the tasmanian tiger
on us but you sure can't blame you know
the ancient extinctions on us something
else was going on and especially
neanderthal nano those a big issue so
what are the reasons that these people
give well here i put a series of issues
that are brought up by paleontologists
who studied in and earth all extinction
and of course all of them were related
to man but until maybe the 2005-2010
near abouts all of the extinction of the
Neanderthals were blamed on climate on
the one hand primarily climate on the
one hand and on the other it was blamed
on humans up competing down just either
killing them outright or using their
weapons more efficiently to hunt the
same game the other fellows hunted or we
had more children you know there's all
these theories but we out competed them
that's the theory and the climate one is
also a human related extinction theory
because we're saying that we were able
to compete under in the lower
temperatures in the colder climates more
better much better than the Neanderthals
so it's also a competition against human
extinction theory right and of course
what drove them away after 2010 that's
only eight years ago was the admixture
theory these people were waiting in the
wings since about nineteen
90s even earlier maybe 1980s this theory
was gaining converts and some people
were driving it at full speed but they
had no evidence so everybody was looking
for evidence one was I Brits did humans
and Neanderthals leave some kind of
intermediate beast you know some hybrid
half-breed whatever that we can say yeah
they interbred and since that didn't
work they went ahead with the
geneticists okay and so the main
arguments raised today our genetic
arguments what that did was put the
geneticists to work it opened a what I
call the goldmine for them thanks to
genetic genetics
going into the business of the
Neanderthal extinction all these centers
around the world that are doing analysis
on Neanderthal DNA oh man they're
receiving clones and they're having a
great time now because suddenly if you
get a degree in genetics out of the
university you have a job they need
people like you and all of that would
have died if they hadn't pointed their
fingers at a mixture and make sure is
the marriage of the two species and
that's how essentially they're saying
that then the end of those died here's a
rundown that I have on my objections to
what these people are saying here's the
first one there's no evidence that
Neanderthals and humans ever met the the
youngest the youngest human we find in
Europe is 35,000 years ago and that's uh
in room Romania they found some human
over there and that's the earliest one
we have today I'm talking about you know
physical evidence bones and last and
earth all according to one of the most
seminal studies died forty thousand
years ago that means
and withal died the last one disappeared
40,000 years ago in the first human
appears 35,000 years ago that's 5000
years difference we have no evidence
other than that that humans and
Neanderthals ever met one possibility is
that there were some mingling in the
Levant especially in Israel possibly in
Iraq the shanidar cave over there but
there are several caves in Israel and if
you go there you find that there's a
there was at least a lot of discussion
on whether those were nando cells and
the jury's still out on that even though
you know they try to brush those
arguments aside and say well yeah they
were nanda Thals I have a problem with
that because I'm not sure that Nano
those who were born in the Arctic would
have gone so far south where it will to
warm climates but here's the genetic
arguments that I have or the arguments I
have against the genetic analysis one is
that humans have no yen dearth of
mitochondrial DNA I found at least nine
studies there probably more that show
that humans and Neanderthals have no
mitochondrial DNA we have mr. sponte
Paabo he's the Guru in the in the
business he specifically specifically
states that humans have no mitochondrial
DNA there's no human walking around with
Neanderthal mitochondrial DNA today so
that we have none what is that why is
that important because mitochondrial DNA
is passed on from mother to children
female or male it's the mother that
passes that I'm that down and if that's
not if we don't have any Neanderthal
mitochondrial DNA
it means we never had and with all
mothers there's no evidence of that
whatsoever in fact the evidence goes
against it the second one is that human
males have known yendo though Y
chromosomes Y chromosome has passed from
father to son male to male and these one
study I think there's been a couple
that humans have known and earth all
males human males have known and earth
all y-chromosomes that means human males
had no Neanderthal fathers that's two
down what did they find they did find a
two percent Neanderthal nuclear DNA and
that's what the genome in 2010 the
report that came out by Svante Paabo is
group that's what they published that
originally they published anywhere from
two to four then they lowered that to
one point five to two point one so if
they kind of drop that number other
people found three to seven percent so
the numbers are being played around with
quite a bit what problem do I have with
that is that look at number a there
forty five thousand years ago the
ischium human from Russia they did a
full genome on this guy he's dated to
about 45,000 years ago he is human he's
not Neanderthal and this fellow has also
I think it was 2.3 percent Neanderthal
DNA that means that 45,000 years ago
here's this human on which we did a full
genome he's got 2.3 essentially 2
percent Neanderthal DNA which is what we
have today and so is so obviously lots
of humans and those days had only 2% and
that is easily explained by showing that
Neanderthals and humans had a common
ancestor making 500 to 800 thousand
years ago and any other issue the over
there pop ones in American Indians have
more Neanderthal DNA than Europeans and
that's a problem and they we you know
throw it under the rug they try to get
people to forget that that statistical
data because they always say that the
way they put it and they say that
non-africans
have more DNA and nuclear nuclear DNA
and earth on nuclear DNA than africans
yeah great and so how about the pop ones
in American Indians who have more
Neanderthal nuclear DNA than Europeans
who lived and mingled and had sex with
the Neanderthals that's got no
explanation whatsoever what they do they
just
sweep it under the rug and that's on the
genetic front on the and the
morphological front that's you know how
these people were built or what they
looked like and what are the
morphological arguments that I raised
against that I say Neanderthals were a
different species than human for this we
have to define the word species that
we're going to talk intelligently I
define it a successful interbreeding in
other words if Neanderthal got in touch
with a human and they had a baby that
baby lived to reproduce more babies than
we can say they were the same species
they may have been different races but
obviously same species on the other hand
if a Neanderthal had sex with a human
and they couldn't have a via Bible you
know kid then we're saying that they're
two separate species they're not just
different races but obviously different
species and that's the definition I use
and of course you can play around with
the definition as long as you tell me
what you mean by species we're going to
have a decent conversation and then what
is the problem I have with that because
the word species applies to humans is
that humans supposedly were born two
hundred thousand years ago where do we
get that well we get that from a couple
sources one is that mitochondrial Eve
regression analysis done on
[Music]
mitochondrial DNA takes us back to a
common ancestor sometime near two
hundred thousand years ago that's one
aspect the other aspect is that they
found physical specimens and there I
listed a couple of them that's the adult
- and Omo specimens in Ethiopia and near
hood in Morocco and they range anywhere
from 160 to 300 thousand years ago so
that's about the extent of the origin of
humans those are considered to be modern
Hugh
assuming that's true and again it's an
assumption that means that we could not
have interbred with anyone in our own
lineage that exceeded 300 thousand years
ago if we're gonna use the word species
correctly we're gonna use it
scientifically if a species is
interbreeding and our species began to
was born anywhere from 200 to 300
thousand years I'll even give it another
hundred let's make it 200 to 400
thousand years ago that means we could
not have interbred from anyone in our
own lineage that exceeded 400 thousand
years ago if we separated from the
Neanderthals like most people believe
out there most paleontologists believe
out there between anywhere between 500
and 800 thousand years ago we could not
have interbred with a Neanderthal simply
because there was too much time that had
passed one and the other one is that
Neanderthals developed in the Arctic
climate while we develop in Africa so we
had we developed in two different
regions so we had to develop different
DNA structure and all this stuff it kind
of goes back to the specialized if one
guys in the Arctic and one guys in the
equator long enough we're talking about
time periods here I mean today if
someone's born in the equator this means
that they're different species
automatically we're talking about long
periods of generations living and dying
in the Arctic and living and dying in
the equator after enough generations
those two groups would not be able to
interbreed Christ they're right because
of this niche specialization and what it
is a mother nature kind of depending on
the environment in which these people
who these individuals have to live and
thrive
mother nature kind of selects their DNA
they're saying or their genes and say
I'm gonna use this gene over here
against the cold for example and this
other guy has to have a gene that fights
against the heat for example and that's
just a general example so the
Neanderthals had to fight against the
cold and that's what they got used and
we had to fight against the heat because
that what we got used to near the
equator near the near Africa
and clearly you know we this selectivity
in our genes made us different species
and of course I argue that nano-cells
did not wear clothes okay we have
specimens well we have one specimen from
from Boxgrove dated to about 500,000
years ago he's allegedly a
heidelbergensis Homo heidelbergensis
parents alleged parents of Neanderthals
and this individual is a farmer he was
he lived around 500,000 years ago and
before that we have flint tools and also
a footprint at Happisburgh
and Pakefield all of these in England I
think I've got a here's a there's a
picture of it I've got that in my book
and if you look at the picture you'll
see what happened here apparently there
was some homo some hominin some hominid
living in the region that you see above
in the picture above okay and what you
see there is that you know there was a
land bridge all the way to the what
today are the British Isles and there
was a lake and these these hominids they
lived around that lake be hunted they
did all their stuff around that Lake and
on one of the borders of the lake was
this glacier that was coming from the
north it was there permanently and they
just got used to this this glacier all
around them you know and so they've
lived around the lake they had water
they killed animals they live their
lives there what happened is about
300,000 years ago the glaciers melted
covered the land and created the English
Channel the channel that separates
France from England and that's what we
have today
and so these guys kind of became
isolated over there whoever was there
they became isolated and and they
probably died on the British islands
many years later all alone in this
island they were separated from the
mainland and and
point here is the following that if
there were some hominins living in
England anywhere from 500 to 800
thousand years ago as suggested by
Pakefield happens burg and and what is
it
Boxgrove that means that these
individuals I'm sure they had no clothes
they got used to the cold and they were
living with her skins directly in touch
with the cold in other words they
probably were wooly they had hair on
underbody we could calm the wooly men
and whoever they were whether whether
they were Homo erectus whether they were
Homo heidelbergensis they they got they
adapted to the cold and so by the time
they have their offspring Homo
neanderthalensis I'm sure Homo
neanderthalensis did not need clothes he
never had clothes Hollywood always paint
something clothes and and tries to make
them look more human but I think he
looked more like a gorilla
he was quite hairy maybe you know and
that's my opinion but what would you
conclude of this animal that lived in
that region Arctic region he had no
reason for clothes and clothes were not
invented at the time 800,000 years ago I
don't think anybody will argue for that
so then they didn't have the tunics I
think the reason they dress Hollywood
actors is that they refused to do the
scene without any clothes no one wants
to see them no no it's not that
no it's that a question visual it's a
question they don't want to stand the
cold weather a bare feet that's they
don't want stuff on the snow like Nana
Thal did I mean Neanderthal had no
sandals I'm sure you know this guy
walked with his bare feet on the snow
just like wolves do today just like
bears do today he was an Arctic animal
he was a woolly man of
of the Arctic and and so he did not wear
clothes whereas we did and maybe that's
when we invented clothes when we went
from Africa to Europe as soon as we
migrated and we started finding maybe
because we were following two herds at
that point when we started feeling the
cold we were not naturally adapted to
the cold and what we did was he invented
clothes we had the intelligence and been
clothed and again well the in event Nano
those are not really European and orthos
there are differences and so the
question is whether the ones in in the
Middle East are really Nandor thoughts
there are noticeable differences
measurable differences and there were at
least in the 1990s up to that time many
paleontologists who did not believe that
the fellows in the Levant are the skulls
and bones they found there are
Neanderthal but of course he had mixture
people had to invent a place where they
mingled and they insist to this day that
the one the ones found in the caves of
Israel specifically are Neanderthals and
that since there was maybe some mingling
with humans coming from Africa that's
where you know the two species began to
bingo and have fun and have kids an en
we have no half-breeds to this day
fanatic admixture theorists constantly
say they found a half-breed and you got
to be very very careful with that claim
the other I mean they found like nine
skulls breeds yeah but no no but there
are some character if you look at a lot
of the skulls
let me put ourselves back up there for a
second here you know if you look a lot
of the skulls found in France and Spain
and so on you know they match these are
all Neanderthals and they've got a few
skulls there you know again there's like
500 bones yeah there's there's bones of
about 500 individuals that we found of
Neanderthal
I think it's more like 400 450 there
abouts and in total so from these four
hundred bones we have to kind of you
know figure out what the story was you
know you have to come up with a plot
what happened and if you look at the
ones in Europe they do match the skulls
match the French match the Spain Spanish
Neanderthals they look the same but when
you compare them against the guys in
Russia you compare them against the guys
in in the Middle East now we have
problems now there are measurable
differences and they kind of squeeze the
guy and say well yeah he's within the
range of neanderthal maybe he wasn't an
answer more than likely he wasn't
there's just too far and too far south
from where the classic Neanderthals were
in Europe the final argument I have
essentially are the social arguments and
just before I do that let me show you
one more thing here and that's you know
again if we wore clothes and Neanderthal
did not and he was the woolly man I
think he looks more like boules had him
drawn by an artist in 1909 that kinda
right over there that's what boules
thought Neanderthal looked like well
obviously that's not what they make him
look like today today he looks more like
a Hollywood actor you know blond
blue-eyed he's got a he's got a draw the
girls attention otherwise you know who
what girl would sleep with and monkey
you know nobody would do that but here
you can see contrast first in the skulls
then in the body structure the main part
there the pelvis and the ribcage and
then you can see also that there's a I
mean that's that's my opinion here right
but I would think that humans if they
ever met humans would have been dressed
and if heads would have been different
and Neanderthals would have been
undressed and with quite a bit of hair
more like a gorilla monkey or whatever a
chimp and their heads were also
different so they look different I don't
think I don't think you can too many
women would sleep with that
and I think that's what they were
essentially some kind of European
guerrilla our swords and then okay so
the last arguments I have against this
is the where do I have somewhere ahead
of your social arguments there it is
social arguments that you know you have
to look at what was their social
structure my my opinion is that both the
humans and Neanderthals they had clan
structures I think the clan structure is
the typical structure of the Paleolithic
and maybe even before and so you you
fight for the clan that's your country
that's your flag
that's your national anthem and the
other clan is your enemy of your own
species let alone about different
species so there there is no friendship
as far as I'm concerned in in the basal
hunter-gathering world well hold on but
didn't the way you frame it it sounds
like they only intermarried within their
own families within their own clans and
never talk to any other clans
essentially yeah essentially it's like
chimps chimps today they kill other
neighboring tribes or clans or whatever
you want to call them this group of
chimps hates the chimps from across the
street let alone gorillas or something
else you know they would react violently
against gorillas entering their their
you know their their lands but they
fight against other chimps and you say
well no how do they have kids
well you know a lot of that is done by
young chimps leaving the clan and young
girls the young females live the clan
leave the clan and young males leave the
clan it happens also among the lions you
know the females the young females they
leave the clan they they wander off and
so do the young males and they find
themselves out there
and they form a new clan if there's
enough land if nobody chases them out or
they we are able to defend their land
and so you know we can imagine this
happening also among me and Athos
there's also probably a rape even though
I doubt that and one of the reasons I
have a problem with a rape in the wild
is that you know no no monkey no ape no
human Betsy hunter-gatherer or no
Neanderthal I think would have ventured
too far from the clan and that's not
because they were gonna be raped it's
because you know the jungle is a
dangerous place
a lion compiles upon the pounce upon you
so you're not a little girl that goes
out there and picks flowers in the
meadow because you don't know what might
come at you could be animal any animal
so you have to be at least within
shouting distance of the clan so for for
to say that uh neanderthal raped a human
female and she she makes all these cries
and nobody comes to her aid I don't
think it ever happened
you know females did not stray far from
the clan you know you know
hunter-gatherers are quite smart
individual if he's gonna survive and one
of those is that he's got to stay close
to the clan he's got to be within
shouting distance and there are no
microphones in the jungle okay you can't
just you know call no no cell phones you
can't call your father and mother your
brother whoever to help you no see you
do it by distance you can't venture too
far from the clan and you better come
home not late at night drunk but you
better be sober and come over
so so the the custom of a
hunter-gatherer I think is very
different what we imagine today and the
other one is that you know humans were
different than socially than anantha
thoughts because we were nomadic we were
coming from Africa moving into Europe
and assuming we met and we were there
when the Neanderthal were still alive
the nanda Thals were on the other hand
you know sedentary they were
no longer moving anymore they were not
wandering they they essentially had
staked their grounds they had their
clans for a living in the region for a
long time they would reproduce and I
think that's part of what gave you know
what caused their extinction the fact
that they were endemic and they also had
to deal with endemic diseases to which
they got used to over time
at first the diseases might have killed
them later on they just made them sick
and eventually maybe they were immune to
them by by simple nature you know after
thousands year of years of being exposed
to them and then again you know the
allegiance was to the clan and it's like
any other great ape today there's other
causes like diseases the fact that we
out competed or gundum we have better
Spears I think all that's nonsense
climate change I'm not sure that the
cold weather would affect Neanderthal
because it would affect wooly or some
other animal much faster than the Ender
thought because Neanderthal did use fire
and if nandha thaw had fire he had an
advantage over all the other animals so
again when the climate gets rough the
rough get moving no no it's not a
question for heat I think they used it
maybe for defense primarily and perhaps
to cook their food maybe they I don't
know it's a possibility that they cooked
their food if they did just by sheer
coincidence without them knowing they
were killing the bacteria that could
affect them also there's the they found
hearse dating to like 50,000 years ago
you know carb carbonized areas you know
Neera Neera Neera stones and so on so so
you know it's pretty much established
that they used fire what they used them
for was it to burn their wives I don't
know you know it could have been
anything but more than likely they
probably cooked their meat another one
is for they probably realize that it's a
good defense against wild animals like
you know cape hyenas and lions and so on
they could use fire to scare them away
so maybe that's how the
this and I'm sure humans use them for
this in the same way anyways the bottom
line is you know I doubt very much
extremely very much I'm very skeptical
of claims that humans and Neanderthals
interbred and again there's no
mitochondrial DNA data to back that up
in fact it's against admixture so is the
Y chromosome data
the only data which is very tiny is the
nuclear DNA we do hit share about 2%
nuclear DNA with the Neanderthals and
that is clearly or very easily explained
by saying that we had a common ancestor
not fifty thousand years ago or forty
thousand but five hundred thousand years
when we parted company so that's in a
nutshell my argument against admixture
which is the reigning theory and again
it's like a lot of this math stuff that
we see in physics once these people
impose it on the masses and the masses
are not careful and just accept the word
of the so-called experts people start
believing and spreading these theories
without analyzing them in any depth and
I have a problem with that because if
the theory is irrational it's it's
nonsense then you know we should discard
it that's that's you know nutshell my
take on the end results
how did nanda those died naina thoughts
died in a different way I think they
they died of old age yeah oh background
extinctions not all I can't vouch for
the one since man came around because
that introduces some complexity into the
picture we do crowd out other animals
but in general before men gain
consciousness and we can say maybe up to
four thousand five thousand years ago
we're talking about that Neolithic Age
here the
even the you know the beginning of
Agriculture and so on until that
happened before then I think all animals
died naturally and they'd and what do I
mean by that I mean that they became old
and what do I mean by old I mean that
their genetic they had they suffered
genetic drift over thousands and
thousands and thousands of years so by
the end of the species life or near the
end of a species life they had lost most
of the genetic diversity that's one
issue and the other issue is that
towards the end of their life they also
became endemic they became sedentary I
think that happens to all species just
before they die humans are now sedentary
you know eight billion people on the
planet we all pretty much live wherever
we are we don't do any exploring anymore
we don't find new continents we found
them all there's no there's no massive
movements like it used to be in the past
you know in the days of the Anderson the
days of cro-magnon you know everybody
traveled because there was no visa no
passports required you can just go
anywhere you want and people just
settled the land and today the land is
settled in fact today we're not creating
new cities other than a couple of China
but other than that you won't find new
cities in Japan you won't find them in
my country in Argentina you won't find
them in the United States we don't
create new cities anymore because all
cities that will end where the world
have already been discovered founded
populated and if anything they'll just
keep growing but no new cities will
start and the reason for that is that we
have no new people you know the people
that are born they stick to the city
where they're at or move to another
existing city they don't go out like but
the Pioneers you know cutting you know
forests out there and starting a new
city it doesn't happen anymore at least
not you know there might be a case here
and there but certainly it's not the
primary mover of migration or people
movements on the planet
we're sedentary we're
Terry species wherever you are you are a
sedentary person whether you travel or
not so so you know this this migration
pioneering kind of work that's over that
happened a long time ago no longer
happens today and what does that mean it
means that if we are endemic if we are
sedentary like the Nando house likely
were at the end and I think all species
that become extinct in a background
extinction become endemic become
sedentary at the end you know those
simply live their lives they get used to
their living their golden age you're
happy where they're at
they got used to where they're at
they're not gonna evolve anymore not
radically and that's where they die and
you know you do have the case of the
redwoods in California they're endemic
the the only place you'll find them is
there I mean I think they moved some of
the seeds or some of the trees to other
parts of the world because they want to
kind of stimulate the growth of redwoods
and other trees similar similar to those
but essentially the redwoods ended up in
California and what you remember is that
you know in the days of the dinosaurs 65
million years ago the redwoods were
everywhere it was one a very popular
tree today it's a little you know
handful over there in California what
happened all the others died essentially
they were taken out of the land was
taken over by other plants and the
redwood slowly ended up in California
that's where they that's the final
Island in which they're gonna die and
the redwoods are an old species I'm sure
of that part of that giveaway is the
fact that they lives to such old ages
you know lived like 2,000 years
they're big another giveaway you know
another clue another footprint when you
have a large tree and it's old and the
third one is that many people are not
aware but the redwoods have developed an
antidote not only to bacteria and other
diseases there is nothing kills them but
worse not even fire affects them they
develop some kind of rosin on the
outside of their skin and there
that you can't burn a redwood and so
they get an antidote even against fire
they developed over the thousands of
years so you know a redwood is is is a
is a dying breed it's in the last stages
of it doesn't mean it's gonna die in a a
year in in the case of plants and trees
and so on they last millions of years so
maybe they're just in their last million
years but the redwoods are not going to
expand assuming we remove everything out
of year we remove humans and other
plants the redwoods are not going to
expand the redwoods die in California
that's their last stand and I think the
same thing happened to the nanda
thousand and athel's were stuck in
Europe they got used to the nice life
they had they're just like idle birds
before them be and maybe Homo erectus
before them and they got used to the the
conditions there they had no reason to
migrate they didn't migrate I think at
the end they just stayed where they were
and that's where they died they died
when their population pyramid overturn
partly that's half of the story the
other half is that they lost their
genetic diversity so I'm sure they had
all kinds of genetic problems towards
the end and they'd have found some
specimens with genetic what is regarded
as genetic problems but I don't think
they're identified property because
people don't really think in these terms
when they're going out there in the
field they're thinking you know what
killed this guy instead of thinking well
maybe something biological what's going
on inside his body over the generations
and and I think if we had God's eyes we
could go back there we can see that the
Nano those suffered in the end genetic
diseases and today we weren't worth
suffering the same kind of diseases
today you know you see all kinds of
genetic diseases today which have
replaced contagious diseases and as as
the primary driver and it's because
we've been intermarried for so long we
who are you gonna marry you're gonna
marry another human and more than likely
you're gonna marry someone from your
or nearby or from your culture and what
does that mean it means that you're all
you're doing is inbreeding you're
propagating the inbreeding that's why we
have I think so many out is
homosexuality today I think it's related
to that the fact that we've been in
reading for so long and I think that
happened also to the Neanderthals I
think it's happening to the Lions you
see lions in their last stand there were
like 135,000 lions just fifty years ago
now there's only 35,000 lions so they're
dying no doubt about it
now you might say well it's because
we're crowding them out well that's part
of the reason no doubt but so we're
accelerating dirty minds that's what
we're doing with that but there's also
another issue that you know lion has to
marry a lion and who's he gonna marry
the lion across the street you know he
kills the lion who's the lion king he
becomes king he takes over the harem and
and what's he gonna do well you might
say well he's a different lion well
maybe not he's he's a cousin of the guy
he killed so so we have marriage of
cousins we have inbreeding extensive
inbreeding and I think that's part of
what's happening in the lion world among
the others hi eNOS their lust
there's only 10,000 hyenas I know
cheetahs there's even less wild dogs
they're even less so we have very few of
these animals they're just for tourism
today then they have no purpose of being
there just undergoing their last stages
of you know until they reach extinction
and we might say well we're a billion
yeah but a billion Anna in a second in a
matter of weeks out geological second
matter of weeks
why because not because of inbreeding
which we are doing but I think the
economy is gonna beat us to it
no of course not of course not that's
why I just mentioned that in passing but
yeah playing all these all these animals
these species for example in Africa are
all collectively dying a background
extinction
no no they're dying in background
extinctions in the sense that they're
competing who
like who dies first yeah if you look at
the numbers it's like they're all
collapsing yeah but where they don't
happening at the same time partly
because we're we have and that's where
it gets complex because you know all
these conservationists and you know
wildlife managers they blame us they say
we are the cause and to some degree
that's true you know we are putting
cement where there used to be jungle and
that kind of shrinks the habitat of the
Lions of the cheetahs of all these other
animals but I think there's another
issue going on and that's that even if
we remove humans let's kill all humans
tomorrow morning all a billion of us
what would happen to the Lions would
they expand and propagating get bigger
no I don't think it would first you know
they're they're used to their sedentary
they live in the regions that they have
already stayed and you would say what is
it why does that Lane go farther out
well they don't they did there's not
enough population to drive that
expansion that's one issue you know and
the other issue is that I think they
lost their genetic diversity if you look
at the diversity among many of the
animals in Africa not to mention the
ones that we commercialize like cows
chickens and pigs and so on you know
they lost all their genetic diversity
there are no mammal no large mammals
with extensive genetic diversity there's
no such thing today we lost it over the
centuries in fact famous study by
British team and I think it's been
corroborated a couple of times already
now and that's that you know chimps in
in a region of Africa right where the
effort that Africa turns the corner and
you know on the Atlantic in that region
they did a study and they found that a
group of 50 chimps troop as it's called
has more genetic diversity within the
troop then all of the eight billion
humans in other if you look at the
genetic diversity between the Chinese
and American and
rushon of south america and african we
are more we have much more commonality
among ourselves than this group of maybe
50 chimps that belong to a single troop
and you say how can that be and I'm
saying that's got to do not with its got
to do primarily with the fact that these
animals are at a given stage in their
genetic diversity depletion so if you
draw a curve from the beginning of the
species to an end of the species you
will find that it loses genetic
diversity through the process of
boundary effect and it crashes and so on
population bottlenecks and it's gonna
lose its genetic diversity over time and
humans are simply more advanced in that
curve than are the chimps that's all it
is we're looking at if we go back in
time to our own lineage we go back to
50,000 years ago we would certainly find
no doubt about it more genetic diversity
among humans in those days and we find
among the eight billion humans today
what do you have to contrast it well you
do have to contrast that there are some
out there that have more than others but
to say hi it's difficult to say hi
because if if we compare ourselves to
the sheep or the XI or against the cows
or any other animal that you choose
whether they're domesticated or wild you
would say okay we have more or we have
less than such like we have more genetic
diversity than cheetahs cheetahs are one
of the animals one of the mammals one of
the large mammals that have the lowest
genetic diversity on earth and there's
very few of them is the question is the
reverse what's the animal with the most
that's not the point the point here that
I'm throwing at Lisa as a theory okay
I'm just proposing I know I said you
probably won't find yeah I don't think
fine I mean I looked at a lot of them I
haven't looked at all the animals on
earth but I think that a lot of the big
animals on earth yeah I'm talking about
small well yeah but then what do you
think the natural thought process would
be they get the other end of the
spectrum to kind of have a contrast of
what you'd find at the newer ends and
what do you find that the older right
now you just have the older ones yeah
in that sense I've not done a full study
on that and all I can say is that the
big animals both wild and domesticated
they have very low genetic diversity
whether you look at horses whether you
look at zebras you look at any animal
very low genetic diversity and basically
we're all clones we're all clones and
and and they just say you know and when
they do these studies there's no genetic
diversity this guy has a little more
this guy has a little less but they're
all very low relatively low for what you
can would consider a species that's
supposed to live another a million two
million ten million more years it's like
something's going on where they lost
their genetic diversity and we cannot
imagine these guys will continue
inbreeding and end up you know for me
you know great masses of animals and
that applies to humans as well you know
it's just not gonna happen
and yeah maybe there are some smaller
animals I don't know I'd have to look at
that but I guess the question is like
from ants yeah but see it's the queen
that matters in the case of bees and
ants not the and the ants are all clones
they are the workers they're all clones
because they're all made by the Queen so
you had to find out what potential yeah
you got to compare Queen against Queen
because the Queen is the only real
[Music]
unique animal in an ant Hall all the
others are just clones or just workers
that slaves that work for her so she's
that she's the one that you know gives
them something to do you know they put
them out in the world they're all the
same but it
about question the way I look at it
simply from a nap from an evidence point
of view which is what you're looking for
but from a reasoning you know I'm just
trying to rationalize this and I'm
saying that there's got to be a curve
due to founder effect and bottlenecks
there's got to be a curve in which
genetic diversity drops over the
centuries over the thousands of years
for any speech yet but you can't read it
we don't have god's history book but but
we do have a couple data points and one
of them is under Neanderthals in fact
there's there's an interesting study
there now again they don't have too much
data but they found when they did the
genome they found that and and one of
the reasons that you reject it a couple
samples was because of this they found
that a sample that was found about 75 to
80 thousand years ago of a Neanderthal
compared to 1/3 of them in fact found
anywhere between 45 and 60 thousand
years ago that 45 to 60 thousand years
ago even though they were in different
regions one was in Spain the other one
was in in Venetia the cave in the old
u.s. la vía you know these had more more
similarities in their in their genetics
then the guy 80,000 years ago so they
said you know this guy who was an older
guy had more genetic diversity than
these guys twenty thousand thirty
thousand years later that they have
determined there's only one data point
but I'm sure you know you'll always see
it that way you'll find that it's it's a
curve for any species and if you want to
know how close a species is to becoming
extinct in a background extinction all
you got to look at is their place on
that curve if you get the Terminator you
got to look at the
position of that species under curve if
it's got very low genetic diversity it's
about to become extinct that's my
general thought on that and with that I
will see you on Sunday and hopefully I'm
praying to God hopefully I'll get that
second installment on real physics so
keep an eye out for it on Sunday I'm
gonna try to see if I can upload it by
then okay we'll see you then see you on
Sunday